BRT WING
WENT NO
BECAUSE OF TL FILING,
THIS VAGUE L FILING
TH RNET TRAIC  SOME WAYS TO THE
CL IT BECAME
CAS
X
WI WEB, ALESOUUMD ON
CLINTON COSIN
WEL R G EN UNDELE. ENDTH
BURIT WEEKX THIS
WAI  TO JUST RECOVEREDON OR ABOD
F DURHAM
UG UWITH MORHISCANDAL.
ALL OF THIS FO
ON HILLARY CON
THAT THA FORME
CANDIDATAT JUST CAN'ITIN EMAILAN
THIS IS FROM -- THIS IS AN E
ENRO
A FELA NGNFLET ME SHOYOECAUSES
X,
DITHIS EMAIL IT FOR COMMENT SAYT
UR REGARDING RVLL
TRS N,T
'RN INTERVIEW.
RSAIDT ANYMORE BUT HE
SAIDHARIGHT IS
HISTORICCTION TO THE MOST
RECENT DURHAFILI
CAT HE INTO THE ABYSS.
HERS
'SVIDINGCE IS DE THEY
ARE IN ON AN
E IN AE DEF
ENT TO KNOW THAT'S
. COVERAGE?
AT WAYS ND VOLUME.VELY VE LOOKE
AUDIENCE
LIKE FOOLS TO BUY ANYTHING SOLD
BEIND WITH
CHANNEL WILL MOSUPAND R .MEANIN
S FRE AYD NONE
, HAVEN'T
OASFAELL.
A HOW THE
THEYSED INNGWATERGAT TRYINPP
SOTH EE S FORMHAS SOMETHING ALNG
Y IGNOD
T,
N VED OF
RIGHT AROUND THE TIME N A SPEE
FUTENOM HAS
THE Y DID O STOP
PEON FL, YOU K BRIAN, FIRST OF H
NTON AS  YOUPE'S CAUSE ITS INURO
ALIN
T
FOX WS
LO, OUT, RU THIS 2016YOU F HO AD
TRNG TO, YOU 'AIGN G
OF DIFFERENCE ANDI SOON LEARNE
YOOWOK A
GOT FOUR TO
E I WOULD GOTWORK WAS
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T NEWTHUSE  .
VEUCTOTATOAT  OOCHBE A QUI TI
AG TOP
OFTENTIMES ABOUT
HIN WH
D RETREATEPRIVRE DIVERSIONROALL
TWS NOT  TRYIN
E UNQUOTE D BALANCED COVERAGE HY
STILL LIO TOUT.
ONTS FEEL.
OF CLINTON'SALK ON F, I K HOUGHT
FOT IN 2OU Y? TNK
MA CAROTR PRESIDEN4,
BUT, LOOK, BRIANANI'HILLARN -- E
IGHT RUN FOR
ING TOAND VE.
.NGS MEANS DRIVH RE REVENUE FORE
Y THOUGHHE OR ENND, BILL CLINTO
LULYT  RUNNINGORE
CRAZY BECATO NARRAVE
W -- OING THATHEY  K
NEWS SO THEY CVE
ADVERTISING DOLLARS INTO THEIR
Y E THEYORE P'S
AS DOCUMENTS
AI BECAME A IAHEREONNIN AND DAV
CAE U OBSERV F
DOZE THE PLACEHAE AT IN THE HEN
RE TRYING TO A NEWT HA A
ORGANIZATION, AS YOUOI ROGERAM A
CHAIRMANE  ON
T  I WOULD AGRTO GO ALG G AN
ALTERNATIVNEWS CHANNEL AND
IN ALTNALEFTZZD I CAN'
>> RIGHT. OINT OUT O THOUGH,A
>>IS NOT ABOUTOUIS IS ABOUT --
DRINREES.WAY TO BLE T
NU -D THIS PROBLHRE
NEWS, QUFR INALISMSOF INEAF
TO BEBEET THENGS AND BEING ABL.
DO TY 3 MILLION PEOPLE WATME
TIME, THAT 1'R T
MONETIZE
ENDP ENTI  CAN NE BIDEN ASEN
R   WITH YOANS
RATIN
SINESS.
>>OCASIO-CORTEZ
TIIGHT.ONG
SHAY
TO KW ISO ENGAGE IIBS HARASSMEN
VID ZURAK,O
.
PEOPLE ON SIDEET THREATSRLS.T IY
SHE'S USINRDS.OFD UPEL
I THINK THTAARN D AO
HATE THE VILLAIN, T  ANDY  TO E
DO IT WITH WOMENTHOUINOF SIS IND
I
REALLY THINKHE
AO - REALLY
PROBLEMATIC.
AND I'M GLAD, YOU KN,  A N', BU
OUT IF THAT HAS,HAELTH
E.EY ARE WAYLOTO V
IT THAODELT CNN
EVENBC.
>> TS UP W
V. PALIN
THE "TIMES" PRLEUTCONTROY ABOUT
SHARING HIS NG BEFOR
NOENE HIPP, ER
GOING  BE MORE AND MORDET  W
LO.INTON SAYS FOX ICLOSE TO AOCS
ME.
MARA, YOU DON'T THINK HILLARY
CLINTON IS AUALL
FOX, RIGHT? HILRYO
SUE FOX NE DIN
COULD HAND.SEAN H ON ITE GRR RA
GOG E SOMETHG LIKE
ATWHEN IT COMES TO A OTHESE SEG
OF PUBLIREORING KEUA
MALICE, BEL DEFAMATION IT FOALU
HAEC THEN'T ST
HAVEO THAT IFA
THEM IN SOME E TO S
ALMOST
IMTAPART O THE
REALLY PL ARTICLE  MOST LYRIIN D